I am absolutely not a pessimist but my
geopolitical spidey sense is tingling
precisely because there are lots of
things that that can go wrong we now
have a very active military conflict
effectively a Russian invasion in
Southeast Ukraine the international
response has been tough sanctions those
tough sanctions are not going to bring
Putin's to his knees his willingness to
provoke and escalate is actually very
great I suppose the worst-case plausible
scenario is the likelihood that the
Russians engage in catastrophic cyber
attacks against Western financial
institutions the geopolitics of the
Middle East has become very very
challenging the big risk around Isis is
that you have two countries that are
effectively fragmented because of the
rise of the world's most powerful best
trained and wealthiest ever terrorist
organization you have more refugees
right now in the world than at any time
since World War two why instability that
comes from these conflicts how many of
those people are getting radicalized
what does that mean as a knock-on effect
in countries that we do care about
economically places like Jordan and
Turkey and eventually of course here in
Europe as well
he risked around Europe is a political
risk as a knock-on effect of austerities
you have very very strong grassroots
disillusionment with Europe
disillusionment with Germany and we see
that in Greece we see it in Spain what
we see it in Portugal we see it here in
the UK the relationship between Germany
and these countries is itself becoming
more dysfunctional the German leadership
of we're going to provide money and
you're going to engage in crippling
austerity that bargain has been broken
decisively in Greece and we're going to
watch it break in other countries this
year and for anyone that's interested
investing in the world's largest common
economic space Europe that's a very
serious problem